king okay but then the white king is
moving towards the black rook this is
the only way to save the game i think
from
um the only potential way to save the
game from duda that last move i think it
was a key move otherwise he was just
dead lost so nice defense from duda but
he's still shaking his head he's still
emotional how can magnus
find this threat to find this last trick
according to the evaluation by it should
be a draw so maybe that the win doesn't
exist for black but he's on the brink
and he needs to force duda to continue
being accurate with less than 20 seconds
on this clock okay threatening checkmate
now with the black rook okay that's why
white escapes with the king and
we're about to see a draw a repetition
of moves maybe i'm sure david
you might as well play
especially with the clock city oh no
maybe i spoke too soon okay another
check and if magnus gives check with
this rook this is the third time we've
seen the position and well so much drama
but it ends in a draw wow
wow what a game that was swinging back
and forth young christoph duda was
fighting for a win eventually though
this is a draw